banana bread is the queen when it comes
to classic quick bread recipes
it's sweet thick tender customizable and
dare we say
moist banana bread is relatively simple
and easy to make but surprisingly a lot
of factors can take your recipe in
different directions there are hundreds
if not thousands of banana bread recipes
out there so we tested a ton of
variations to bring you tasty's ultimate
banana bread
[Music]
we're going to start with preparing a 9
by 5 inch loaf pan spray it with some
nonstick cooking spray line it with
parchment paper and then spray it again
we'll set that aside and move on to
browning our butter add the butter to a
non-stick pan over medium-high heat
cook and stir occasionally until the
butter turns amber brown and smells
nutty the process will take about three
to four minutes but make sure you're
watching carefully so the butter doesn't
burn
quick tip brown your butter in a light
colored pan so you can see the butter
brown more clearly once you have that
nice amber brown color remove the pot
from the heat and set aside to cool for
about 10 to 15 minutes now that our
butter has cooled we'll add that to a
large bowl along with our brown sugar
using brown sugar instead of white sugar
will add more of a caramel flavor and
moistness to your banana bread we're
adding one cup here quick tip if your
bananas aren't extremely ripe just add
another quarter cup of sugar
we'll use a hand mixer to beat until
evenly combined about one minute
next we'll add one egg and whip it with
a hand mixer this will help leaven and
lighten the texture of the banana bread
we're only whipping for about three to
four minutes because we only want a
little bit of air if we whip it too much
the bread will rise and then fall
because it's too dense now wouldn't be
banana bread without bananas
for ultra delicious banana bread you
want those bananas to be mostly brown
and slightly over it like these brown
bananas are sweeter and have a more
pronounced banana flavor they're also
easier to mash and will better
incorporate into your batter we tested a
couple different ways to ripen bananas
more quickly if you're ever in a time
crunch we bake them in the oven at 350
degrees fahrenheit for 15 minutes while
the bananas did soften they lost that
caramelized banana flavor you get when
you let them ripen naturally they were
also a lot less sweet leaving the loaf
tasting like it was missing something we
also tried them in a brown bag with an
apple and it did nothing in fact only
the apple ripened the next day we took
the apple out and just let the bananas
sit in the bag they didn't ripen any
faster than the ones we let sit on the
counter
simply put the best way to ripen bananas
is the old-fashioned way time and trust
us when we say it is worth the wait for
this recipe we're using two cups of
mashed bananas we found that it's best
to measure bananas in cups because they
differ in size one person's four bananas
might equal two cups
while another person's bananas might
only equal one cup
a fork is probably the most popular
mashing method it takes a little more
effort but it works great
if you're looking for something easier
try using a potato masher if you're
looking for a little less mess you can
actually mash the banana inside the
banana peel like this
add the mashed bananas to a medium bowl
along with some full fat sour cream
emphasis on the vole the reason we're
using sour cream instead of milk creme
fraiche or greek yogurt is because sour
cream adds moisture with a little bit of
tang the acidic properties of sour cream
also help tenderize the loaf to give it
that soft texture let's add a little
vanilla extract and fold to combine
let's move on to our dry ingredients to
another mixing bowl we're going to add
all-purpose flour
kosher salt
baking soda
and cinnamon there are a lot of spice
options you could add to banana bread
cinnamon nutmeg cloves allspice cardamom
and even ginger but cinnamon is going to
pair best with the dark chocolate we'll
add to the batter later now that our dry
ingredients are well combined we're
going to alternate folding the flour and
mash bananas into our creamed mixture we
want to start and end with our dry
ingredients to avoid getting a dense
loaf we'll mix everything until just
incorporated we don't want to over mix
the batter won't be perfectly smooth and
that's okay there's some debate out
there about whether to add chocolate or
nuts to banana bread but it tasty we are
team chocolate for obvious reasons we
love using dark chocolate chips because
they complement the sweetness of the
loaf pour the batter into the prepared
loaf pan and we are ready to bake
okay we lied we have one final step
we're going to sprinkle some turbinado
sugar on top this step is totally
optional but it's going to give our loaf
a little crunch and texture drooling yet
because we sure are
now we can pop our banana bread in the
oven we're going to bake it at 350
degrees fahrenheit for about 60 to 70
minutes you'll know it's done when you
insert a toothpick in the center and it
comes out clean check out that golden
brown goodness if only you could smell
this through your screen
wow we're going to set the loaf on a
wire rack to cool for at least one hour
then it is time to dig in we like to
serve our banana bread hot room
temperature or even toast it the next
day enjoy it for breakfast for dessert
or as a snack however you wish to savor
it slathering on some salted butter is a
must remember when life gives you
bananas make banana bread we can't wait
for you to make our recipe let us know
what you think you can find this and
more banana bread inspired dishes on
tasty.com thanks for watching
we hope you found this appealing
[Music]
and cut and done